and welcome to the simons institute my
name is peter bartlett i'm the associate
director here i'm very glad to have you
uh here in person for um
for this workshop um we're a
collaborative research institute for
theoretical computer science we run
these uh semester-long programs
typically two each semester and
geometric methods in optimization and
sampling is one of the ones we're
running this semester it's brought about
80 uh visitors in total
to to berkeley um thanks to the nsf for
its support of the program through the
foundations of data science institute um
and and welcome to the second workshop
in geometric methods and optimization
and sampling uh dynamics and
discretization pdes sampling and
optimization
so first of all a big thank you to the
organizers for putting together a
fantastic program for this week uh
thanks to katie craig and simone di
mourinho
um and i'll hand over to katie in a
moment uh to introduce the workshop
uh just a few logistics things so we do
ask that you don't bring food and drinks
into the auditorium we try to keep clean
water is is fine but please uh have have
those things outside um we'll have we'll
have uh
food and and coffee and so on
at the breaks for lunches you're on your
own
there are plenty of options
during those
those lunch breaks there are lockers on
the far side of the building if you'd
like to use those they work with a with
a pin so you don't need to carry your
stuff around the campus
um
and you know as you can see we're in a
hybrid format with live and zoom
speakers
and and audience i guess um
uh there's also video streaming on
youtube and things are archived
there um afterwards also uh omid farr
here is our videographer he'll be
helping with the
uh hooking up your computers if you're
if you're speaking in person and helping
on the zoom also uh and a big thank you
also to uh ashley hassan
uh at the back of the room here uh our
events coordinator who did all the local
arrangements thanks ashley
[Applause]
all right so welcome it's great to see
see you all here in person i'll hand
over to katie
thank you very much peter and of course
i think a very important person we
should thank is both peter bartlett uh
and shafi goldwasser who are the
directors of the uh simons institute so
thank you very much for hosting us
[Applause]
so uh this
workshop is part of the semester-long
program in geometric methods and
optimization optimization and sampling
uh which
is our lead organizer for that
semester-long program is felipe rigoles
i'd also like to to thank him as well
for getting us all together and making
this happen under slightly unusual
circumstances
thank you
[Applause]
and so i'm very excited about uh this
week's workshop i'm very grateful to my
co-organizer simone du marino for
helping put together this uh wonderful
program um it's going to be you know
especially close to my heart to see the
connections between pdes and these kind
of geometric methods and sampling and
optimization which is the subject of the
program so i think we are miraculously
about right on time so i'm just going to
make one small
administrative note um the final speaker
today had to cancel due to a loss in the
family and so dohyun kwan has kindly
offered
to take that spot and so then we can
adjust and add someone else later in the
week um so today from 3 45 to 4 15 pm we
will actually be hearing from uh dohen
so thank you very much john for doing
that for us i know it's not easy always
to shift these schedules around at the
last minute
okay so with that i think i'm very
pleased to introduce our first speaker
michaela jacobelli from eth zurich
michaela is going to be speaking on
singular limits for blasov equations via
kinetic type vosserstein distances so
thank you very much michaela
so thank you very much katie and thank
you very much simone too
for organizing this great program and
also for for inviting me speaking to
speak about my work
uh i i wish i were there
but i'm grateful that you gave me the
opportunity to to talk remotely
so uh let me start um
so that line of today's talk is the
following so i would like to present and
to introduce some
basic kinetic models for plasma physics
so we'll start with the classical model
that is the blaso poisson equation and i
will also briefly present
uh
the vlaso poisson model for for
ions that is a variant that takes into
account the movement of ions while the
classical one considers the movement of
electrons in the plasma
then what i would like to talk about is
um the quasi-neutral limit that is a
singular limits that put in relation the
blasto poisson system
and the blossom system with massless
electrons with a sort of kinetic version
of euler equations
and all this will rely on the study of
stability
and the stability of the solutions for
this plus of system will be measured in
terms of the buses and distances
and finally i will explain how using
some let's say
tailored kinetic assessing type
distances one can improve these
stability estimates and so also improve
the results about quasi-natural limits
so let me start from the beginning so
what is a plasma a plasma is a united
gas so it's a gut imaging a gas
where due to high temperature or for
example
if this gas is subject to high magnetic
fields
the electrons detach from the ions so
instead of having a classical
neutral gas then you find yourself with
the cloud of
of
charged particles so for example i if
you consider that
the ionization is complete you have ions
and electrons
and
for this reason plasmas are highly
conductive and each particle feels the
action of all other particles so we will
talk about
a situation where instead of having a
short range collision we consider
long-term interactions
and in general each particle feels an
action that is given by the
electromagnetic fields generated by all
others so
this is a bit
the the model that we have in mind and
this model and this um
this physical object that is a plasma
can be modeled
at different
scales so for example one can decide to
follow each particle and follow the
through the newton's laws mechanics and
this is uh certainly correct and will
give a deterministic and totally
precise description of the plasma but is
unpractical and is actually possible
because the number of particles we will
deal with is is huge
or you can decide to consider the plasma
as a continuous and so as a fluid
description
or also you can have something in
between a macroscopic fluid description
and a microscopic newtonian description
and this scale is the kinetic theory
scale and this is what we will discuss
in this talk
so the the most classical
kinetic model for plasma is the
blastoposome system and this system
consists in a transport equation
whose unknown is
f of tx and v and this unknown is the
repartition function
of the electrons in this case so what
does it mean it means that at the fixed
at time t
uh f of t x v
d x and d and d b
will tell you how many particles are at
time t with position x and velocity b
so so we are we are looking at a
statistical description of this plasma
so we will not follow each each
particles trajectory but rather we will
follow the evolution of this repartition
function
and
we will have this transport equation
and
these
electrons move under the force field
that is e and d is
the electric field
and this minus graph of u where u is the
electric potential
so in this case um
i'm just presenting you
the system that model the easiest
possible scenario we can think of so
it's a scenario when we don't consider
magnetic effects so we are in
electrostatic approximation and so we
only describe a dilute plasma without
considering a magnetic effects
and then we couple this transport
equation with a poisson equation so we
know that the equation for for the
potential u
is a poisson equation so we have the q
sat is phi minus laplacian of u equals
rho minus one where rho is the
electron's density
so this is one peculiarity
of the lasso poisson system and it is
that
the coupling doesn't happen
uh at the level of the function f but it
happens through um a quantity rho
that is let's say a macroscopic quantity
so in kinetic theory the microscopic
observables are always
integral with respect to
to the velocity or let's say other
quantities of
f of t x and v
so this is uh
just a brief introduction and
in this case we are following
the evolution of the electrons
and what happens to the ions is that
since
they are much more massive than the
electrons they can be considered as a
fixed background
so in this equation you see that rho is
the density of the electrons and one
represents the density of the ions
okay of course
if we have a totally unionized gas we
will have a cloud of electrons and we
will also have these these ions that can
act as a fixed background
and these two uh
let's say these two family of particles
move at different time scales
so one can decide also to
to consider the time scale of the ions
and in this case the system
has to be modified to take into account
this
so this is the the second model i would
like to present uh briefly
and in this case you still have the the
same transport equation but the coupling
is a bit different
why because now
f is the repartition function of the
ions
while uh
since the electrons are very light they
move extremely fast and they immediately
reach their thermodynamical equilibrium
e to the u so they reach this maxwell
boltzmann law equilibrium
and now our coupling is minus laplacian
of u equal rho minus e to the u where
rho is the ions density
and let's say both systems are
physically relevant but the first one i
present is presented is um
really well studied since a long time
while the system of for the ions is less
well-studied also because of this
external linearity that
let's say add some difficulties in the
in the in the analysis from the pde
point of view
and uh
but in it's very this this system is uh
very present in the physics literature
for example
it's used to model the dynamics of
rarefied united gases but also for it's
used for
describing the
the formation of iron acoustic shocks
and uh to describe the expansion of
plasma and tobacco in particular this
last line of research is very recent and
and very active
and now we have this uh two
kinetic systems and there are several
classical questions that one can ask and
these questions are related to the world
business so
existence
uh uniqueness and
stability
of the solutions but also to
singular limits why singular limits
because as i mentioned at the beginning
there are
different levels of description of
gases and plasmas so one can ask for
example whether
we can derive this uh this equation
from the n particle systems in what is
called the mean field limit
but also we can ask ourselves whether
we can
put in relation this mesoscopic model
with them with a more let's say fluid
description and these are usually called
hydrodynamical limits and this is more
in the spirit of what i will talk about
today
um
so uh we will focus on these singular
limits um
in the direction mesoscopic to
macroscopic
so let me now introduce uh what is the
by length and what i mean by
quasi-neutrality so to introduce
quasi-natural limit so plasma as
physical objects have several
physical
length scale and
we can decide to
to focus on some of them in particular
if you look at the plasma as a whole in
a box um since it is um
very is a very highly conductive object
if you add a charge
this chart will be really neutralized
so in general you can consider it as a
neutral object if you look it from far
away
but if you zoom enough
at in particular if you zoom at the
level of the balance then you will see
uh local uh
charges and charge unbalances so regions
where you have more electrons than ions
and vice versa
so this this uh the by length is um
a typical length scale for plasma and
the fact that
this step i length is very very small
compared to the length of observation
is in the very same definition of a
plasma because this ensure that we have
a plasma like behavior
in a position with a single particle
single charged particle behavior
so if we decide to take into account the
existence of this parameter lambda d
we can
write epsilon we can we can call epsilon
um a quantity that is lambda d divided
by the observation length
and this epsilon will appear in front of
the laplacian
in our coupling so we will have a minus
epsilon square laplacian of u equal row
minus one
and since this quantity is extremely
small and is let's say sometimes assumed
to be essentially zero in uh
in the physics literature
it's interesting to understand what
happens in the in the limit as epsilon
goes to zero
so this is this procedure is called
quasi-neutral limit so i call it epsilon
because we like to call epsilon the
quantities that we send to zero
um
so uh if we consider this the balance
then we have a scaled lasso poisson
system with this parameter epsilon that
that is in front of the laplacian in the
coupling
and if we just
set epsilon to zero
we formally find a system that is called
kinetic incompressible euler
and i will now explain why
it is called kinetic incompressible
euler but let me just observe
uh this this system so we still have the
same transport equation
now the term quasi-neutral limit
becomes evident because in this system
rho is
identically one
so the density of the electron is
constantly equal to the density of the
ions so the gas the plasma is neutral
and with e e is minus graph u
but in this case u is defined implicitly
by the fact that we want to ensure this
um
this constraint rho equal to 1 to all
true for all times so you acts as a
brown is lagrange multiplier
like in euler the pressure
uh is a constraint that enforces the
the fact that the divergence is zero
so it enforces the incompressibility
constraint here
uh
uh our electrons move under the action
of a gradient that forces them to
to be um to a density constant equal to
one
and this is why this limit is called
quasi-neutral
so the first one to notice this
connection between
the kinetic this this system and fluid
dynamics has been bernie at the end of
the 80s and beginning of the 90s that
have been a series of work
and in particular
what he showed is that
if f is um monokinetic so f is given by
rho of x so a function in x times a
delta in velocity so it means that the
velocity is concentrated so delta is
at b minus u of tx
then we know we can we can see that
f is a solution of this kinetic
incompressible euler system if and only
if rho is identically 1 and u solves the
incompressible euler equations
so um this is very easy to verify so you
if you take
the kinetic incompressible euler system
and integrate it in db you find the
row identically one and if you multiply
that by v and uh integrate in db you get
um
the the then compare the euler equation
of course this only at the formal level
the rigorous justification is
much more delicate
in fact i mean there have been several
uh results starting from the case of
cold ions so that means um the case of
monokinetic solutions
but
in general there have been several
advancements from different point of
views
um and i will just focus today
on
i will just mention some results that i
will directly use
uh in the proofs but in particular i
will i would like to mention the the
results by brenne
who who found this connection and who
proved that the coincidental limit holds
true for well-prepared monokinetic data
so that the kind of data that i just
showed you
then what will be fundamental for us
is um
is the work
by grenier
who proved that because neutral limit
holds true if the initial datum enjoys
some analytic
let's say properties that i will show
later
and
besides these positive results there
have been also negative results
so for example daniel and maximore
daniel
and tuongo yen and again um daniel
and uh federico
um
tackled the problem of understanding the
question of stability and disability and
this already shows that this is a very
delicate limiting procedure
and the fact that it's a delicate
limiting procedure can also be
understood let's say heuristically
by thinking at the fact that we are
trying to solve loss of poisson by
sending the laplacian to zero so
it cannot be let's say easy
uh to
to to maintain
uh good properties in this limit
so the proof by grenier uh it's been
fundamental because it in
is a positive result and it shows that
under the assumption that the initial
data f0 epsilon are bounded in analytic
norm so in in some analytic norm in in x
and that the initial density is
uniformly close still in this norm two
to one
uh then uh the limit because in other
limits true on some finite time and
interval up to some correctors that
takes care of plasma oscillation but
this is
a technical let's say a technical
detail
and
here is where buses and distances enter
the question is the following if we have
a positive result
in terms of
analytic
let's say
requiring for an analytic control on the
initial datum the question the natural
question is can we go beyond analyticity
and one way could be to perturb this
initial data
and this is exactly what i will do now
but what has been proved to be crucial
is um to
to select well
how to measure the size of this
perturbation so
uh how to how to perturb correctly this
this initial datum and one way to do it
is through the notion of buses and
distances that you
all know but let me just
uh mention again the definition so buses
and distances are
a family of distances on probability
measure that matters the topology of
weak star convergence on compact sets
and if you have new and new two
probability measures then the p-value
system distance between mu and u is the
infield on all the couplings between mu
and u
of the integral of x minus y to the p
d pi x y
all to the to the right power
and this uh set of coupling
um
is is made of probability measures that
in the in the product space that has as
first marginal new mu and the second
marginal nu
and the uh the vastus and decent or mont
controversies um have been used uh in
the context of kinetic theory since the
70s uh since the seminal work of the
brushing in the context of um
glass of systems also the work by tanaka
in the context of
boltzmann equation
and the reason why these distances are
so handy in the context of
kinect reasons the kinetic theory
are more than one but in particular you
can think
about the fact that they are
very good at measuring
the distance between discrete objects
and for example
if we want to study the derivation of a
kinetic equation from the system of n
particle
and particles then you you would like to
to see
uh and to clearly see
uh the distance between uh
uh
measures um
centered on deltas and uh
the buses and distance is very good and
very subtle to do so
while other uh common distances between
probability measures are quite rough so
for example the total variation distance
between two deltas if they don't
coincide it's always two
no matter how close are these two deltas
while the vast system distance between
two deltas is the distance between their
support
so this is one one reason and the other
is that demetrius the topology weeks are
convergence uh measures and so
uh is a good let's say these are good
distances on which
trying to to make estimates and measure
stability
this was just um to explain a bit
how this um vases and distance enter
into play
and
this is the first
result i would like to present and it um
it's a positive result obtaining
collaboration with daniel anchan that is
um at the corporate technique and what
we did is to take um initial datum that
is a perturbation of grammy initial
datum so f0 epsilon is the sum of jeep
syrup silent that satisfies all the
hypotheses of granite theorem plus
a small perturbation h0 epsilon and how
small as this perturbation to be this
perturbation is to be exponentially
small investors time
in buses and one in this case
then in
under this hypothesis there exists a
positive time such that any weak
solution of the rescaled plasma poisson
system starting from from zero epsilon
converts to a solution of the kinetic
incompressible oil starting from g zero
that is the limit
as epsilon goes to zero of g zero
epsilon
and now we we noticed that
in order to have this um
this this result we are asking for quite
stringent condition at time zero on the
on the size of this perturbation and the
natural question is
is this condition really um very
stringent is what what is the kind of
condition we can expect world
and actually
the analyticity assumption of grenier on
g zero epsilon and exponential smallness
of the perturbation h0 epsilon are
necessary because
first grenier
explained this fact but then it's been
rigorously proved by anfan and loree
there exists smooth homogeneous
equilibrium mu v of the kinetic
incompressible euler system
such that
uh even if
we control
as many derivative as we want
and we have a polynomial control so
we have a control in
epsilon to the n
then um the quasi limit is false so
there are negative results that shows
that a polynomial control is not enough
so of course uh
there is still something between
polynomial control and exponential so is
it open is an open question to really
detect the sharp regime uh for this for
this sort of limits but still we can say
that having an exponential smallness is
something that we can
accept
of course the situation
as a big caveat the caveat is that the
result that i showed you holds in
dimension 1
while
blast off systems in general are very
highly dimension dependent because
estimates get worse with the dimension
that goes up
so the in dimension 2 and three we
couldn't really prove the very same
result so we try to apply the same
strategy
that still holds
although we need to use different tools
and what we can what we can obtain is
that under the same kind of uh set of
hypotheses so we have initial datum that
is a perturbation of a grainy uh initial
datum
uh then if we impose this perturbation
is doubly small double exponentially
small and we also have to impose
uh boundedness of infinite energy at
time zero and
compact supporting velocity
uh well the compact supporting velocity
here is just for convenience but it can
be relaxed
a bit
uh then we still have that the west
natural limit holds true
but you can see that um
we had to add one exponential that is
not really ideal because there is no
reason in principle why
the results should degenerate so much
in higher dimensions
okay
and in particular
the key uh of the difference between the
one-dimensional case and the two and
three-dimensional case is that for
blasto poisson
when we have at our disposal a set of
very good stability estimates in
dimension 1 that are so-called weak
strong stability estimates it means that
i don't need to have
integrability in both
solutions so in the density of both
solutions but i just need integrability
on one of the two
while from dimension to higher
the results that we have at our disposal
are just weak strong stability yes a
strong strong stability estimate it
means that we need to impose
um
that the density associated to both
solutions
are in infinity for all times so
this is one big difference
so what happens for for the massless
electron system i would like just to
mention that
um
the idea is to try
to mimic the
the results that we have in blood
poisson
but we didn't have also
the classical well poisonness
theory at our disposal so in the first
series of paper with megan griffin
pickering that now is at dharam
university we proved first
um
the
the world postness of the blastoposome
system for massless electrons
with the kind of theorem that exactly
matches what we had
for
blasopoison
and by doing this we developed a set of
estimates
that allowed us to replicate
the same proof that i had with daniel 1
in the case of
of ions but in this case the control is
uh really
really not not good because this x4
means an envelope of four exponential
so
uh there is no way this is a sharp or
any or not even a really good
assumption at time zero
so we are still trying to to improve
uh the the case for ions using
some new tools so the strategy of the
proof in the case of glass of poisson
really
really lays on a famous result by le
pere
who proved
uniqueness for lasso poisson
when the density
the density of the
is in infinity
so here we we use a kind of stability
estimate
al aleppa that is a strong strong
stability estimate and we assume f1 and
f2 to be the solutions of the scaled
system row one and row two the
associated density we assume that at
times zero they are
in a lymph nicky then we have to prove
that they remain in l infinity for all
times
and what we can prove is an estimate uh
in terms of devices and to distance and
this estimate
uh is
this w2 at one f2 smaller than e to the
log to something
uh it would be c epsilon t
where the constant depends on epsilon
and the elementary norms of the two
densities and here you can see where
this exponentials where the double
exponential comes from
so then we apply the estimates um with
f1 equal the the the
smooth part of our initial datum
and f2 being the the all initial datum
of epsilon
and then we we need to bound the
lymphatic norm of the density of epsilon
and and this is where
uh it enters also the study of the
growth of the support in velocity of
epsilon
and we conclude applying grenier result
to epsilon
so thanks to this strategy we obtained
the validity of the quasi-neutral limit
for blaso poisson for initial data that
are double exponential perturbation of
analytic functions and still using this
strategy we obtained
the the positive limit also in the case
of ions but with the envelope of the
four of the four exponentials
so if you read the strategy of this
proof
you notice that there is not really a
lot of room to improve
this rate of convergence except in the
stability estimate in boston's time
so and this is where this
new let's say kinetic passage approach
comes to play
and that is the following
um in kinetic theory we have okay the
time but then we have the evolution
of the position variable and evolution
of the momentum so of the velocity
and these two evolutions don't play the
same role
in fact if you if we write
the
characteristics the system of the
characteristic is associated to to the
solution f5 of glass of poisson
then if you differentiate with respect
to
x then you get if you differentiate x
with respect to t
you get the velocity so if you
differentiate the position you get the
velocity but if you differentiate the
velocity then you get
the electric field
so of course
uh the velocity term will uh will
contribute in a more singular way or
anyhow in a way that is more complicated
to estimate
so the basic idea
is to abandon let's say
the goal of measuring this um
this convergence directly doing the
crown wall on the vases and two distance
but to introduce a new quantity
that
can be bounded from above and below
from the buses and to distance
but that takes into account this natural
anisotropy that is present in in kinetic
in kinetic problems so what i what i
mean is that i can penalize
uh
the the role of the position to gain
something in
when i differentiate in the velocity and
this is uh not a completely new idea
because it was already used for example
in the context of blast of the question
by
lazarovich and lazarovich and piccol
in the context of memphis limit
but they added a parameter and then
optimized in in in this parameter and
this is something that i've also done
with mega griffin pickering
uh just to try to maximize a certain
range of parameters but here the
let's say the idea is to is to
penalize this position with a certain
lambda of t that is a function of q of t
itself
so it will vary along the flow in a
non-linear
and implicit way
because now we have let's say now we
have on the on the left-hand side q of t
and on the right-hand side we have
lambda of t that is a function of q of t
so in our regime we look for q of 0 that
is very very small
and for our purposes a good choice is to
select lambda of t
to be the modulus of log of q of t
then the idea is to prove that your q of
t is well defined in our regime and
differentiable
to compare and then let's say to to do a
grammar argument on this new quantity q
of t
and to compare
finally compare q of t
to
the classical bus system to distance
and so this will give
us a new estimate uh versus n2 distance
between the
solution f1 and solution f2 to the
square
and is given by this expression that may
not be
transparent but let me just
conclude by explaining a bit this kind
of improvement
so
as a comparison with the estimate if we
assume that that these buses and two
distance at time zero between f1 and f2
is uh very small it's of order of theta
then
we have a good control
uh for a time of the order log log theta
while with this new bound we have a good
control for a time that is of the order
square root of log theta so on a longer
time scale
and i would not expect to have the
cleaner
let's say
log theta
estimate
because since uh
in this situation
the density has to be an infinity
then the electric field is only log lead
sheets
so i would not expect a classical
groundwall argument to hold so
this is to just to explain this kind of
stability estimate
and then
in the case of causing ultra limit i
used this idea with um
lambda of t equal to epsilon minus 2
uh log of q of t
and what i could obtain is a result in
the spirit of the result that obtained
with danielle 1 so under the very same
hypothesis
but this time in dimension two and three
i only have to require that um
the perturbation is exponentially small
in inverses and so instead of the double
exponential
and so to conclude uh this method of
weighting
uh of building let's say some kinetic
vast system quantities uh can is very
flexible because for example um
it allowed me to to improve some other
estimates of the brushing
kind or
it can be employed
to prove by procursivity results
and also doesn't only
doesn't only apply to kinetic
systems because it applies to all
situations where you have a transport
equation
and you have that the evolution in one
of the variable is uh enjoys
uh more regularity than the evolution in
the others so it doesn't really rely on
the second order structure but it relies
only on the fact
that
the evolution in one variable is
better than in the other
and some ongoing projects related to
that
including proving the quasi-neutral
limit in the ionic vast time
loss of equation
so trying to understand how let's say if
we can obtain just one or two
exponentials i still don't know
what would be
the desirable estimate
and then also to try to apply this
method to get improved convergence rate
for particle models so for me for limit
and this method can also be applied
in the quantum
world
to the so-called mons can fund to munch
control which distances um
introduced by goals and paul uh and also
by golds paul and m1
so this this is all i wanted to say and
i thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much um
the there are microphones hanging from
the ceiling so if anyone has a question
you can even ask from your seat
yes um if i can ask
for uh so
you show that the singular limit is
valid for finite time do you have an
idea what happens as you reach that
finite time
well
plasmas are inherently unstable
so in general i expect instability
rather than stability so this
quasi-neutral limit
is always holding for
short times and
with in situations where the initial
data are really well prepared
or in situations where for example we
impose
uh structural properties so like for
example the initial data has to verify a
certain penrose condition
but in general i expect instability
this this this is stability mechanism
are also well described by grenier
already and he described uh the
two-stream instability but also the the
easy fact that in this scaled system
uh if you imagine if you take an elect
an electron then
others electron may turn around it with
the velocity
of the order epsilon to minus one so it
it's quite an unstable situation so i
don't expect this limit to hold for for
a long time
thank you
you're welcome
i guess i i wanted to uh if you don't
mind saying a few more words about
uh you you're saying how this is a
flexible technique that would work
whenever you maybe have a
one variable that has a better
regularizing behavior than another would
you mind to go back to the uh the
equations that you were considering here
and talk about um to what extent
different aspects of the
or view of the original pde
um
[Music]
so for example yeah
yeah perfect would you mind just talking
about uh yeah
uh how we can see the flexibility of the
approach in this context for example is
there is there a natural thing here uh
which could be
changed or um just as a example of what
you were saying yeah
yes of course um well what i was meaning
is the following so there are different
ways to improve the stability estimates
and this system this uh this approach
has to be adapted to the very specific
question you have in mind so for example
there is another classical stability um
estimate that holds for glass of systems
so not for not it's not doesn't it
doesn't all for blasto poisson but it
also for blasto system with smooth
interaction potential and it is the du
brushing estimate
uh that is an estimate in the in uh bus
system one
uh that give you um
an exponential control
so exponential stability
now this estimate uh has been really
used extensively since the 70s to prove
mean field limits and in general to
measure stability
but it is highly suboptimal because it's
already an exponential
uh let's say um estimates even even at
time zero so even when you would expect
them
so even for a potential that is zero so
even when you would expect a much better
control so like a linear control
so to improve that estimate i didn't
penalize
the position what i did is that i added
the shift in time
so i still uh did the groundwater on a
quantity that is vastly like but it
wasn't buses and like in the sense that
i penalized the position but it was a
bust and like because it had bounced
from above and below with buses than one
but it was shifted in time
then another application could be um in
the context of of hypocresivity
um but and this has been done for
example by samir salam who uses the
variant of this uh of this distance and
for example another application is um
can be this this is a work in progress
in the derivation
of loss of poisson
equation from the r3 equation in uh in
quantum mechanics so
there are some vases and like distances
in quantum mechanics that have been uh
introduced in the recent recent years
both uh when measuring objects that both
that belong to the quantum world so
buses and distance versus unlike one
distance between uh quantum objects but
also quantum buses and distance that
measure the distance between a quantum
object and
a classical one so for example use it to
derive lasso poisson from artery
and
since they rely on stability estimates
that are very similar to leper
i believe that this can this method can
be applied in that situation too
uh although i still don't know precisely
how to make it work but i i believe it
so but what i was what i was pointing
out is that i was not using
exactly that b is the derivative in time
of x
this can work even if um
i'm in a situation where x
uh the the let's say the evolution with
respect to one variable
is smoother or
some better properties with respect to
the revolution on the other variable
now i don't have yet a precise example
in mind but it can happen
that
the evolution in one variable is uh is
better than devolution in the other
and the only thing i wanted to point out
is that several improvements
um
can can really in this setting can
really rely on the fact that we have a
second order structure and this is not
the case with these uh vasa stand like
distances
thank you very much um all right well
with that i think let us uh
thank michaela
so thanks a lot
and i see that our next speaker